non
les arbres sont d'extraordinaires
machine à purifier l'air sans arbres
libellé t'offre mais au printemps comme
toutes les plantes à fleurs ils se
reproduisent en relâchant beaucoup de
matières allergènes en très peu de temps
la canapé cette importance à livre
beaucoup de services qui sont très
positifs et dont on a besoin au niveau
de notre santé il y en a un qui est
négatif c'est la production pollen en ce
moment il ya du pollen partout dans
l'air de montréal c'est normal la ville
préfère planter des arbres mal qui
produisent du pollen et tolèrent moins
bien les arbres femelle qui ont des fous
de recouvrir les trottoirs et les rues
de sa mère de fruits et de noix pour
répondre à cette intolérance on la
commence à planter des clous ont conduit
ou des variétés qui sont dites stérile
mais la réalité c'est que la grande
majorité d'entre elles ne sont pas
stériles elles sont mal donc elles
produisent quand même des flammes et
seulement des fleurs mâles qui donc
produisent du poil 1 alors on ne
remplace un problème d'esthétisme
d'intolérance par un problème de santé
publique on estime en effet qu'un
montréalaise sur cinq souffre
d'allergies saisonnières que la moitié
d'entre eux ont des symptômes sévères et
que la période d'allergies s'allonge
d'année en année non seulement la saison
2 des pollens est allongé mais leur
potentiel allergènes oscille le pollen
eux mêmes vont causer plus d'allergies
puis des allergies plus sévère en raison
des changements climatiques mais aussi
des interactions avec d'autres polluants
atmosphériques comme le co2 pour aider
ceux qui souffrent d'allergies il
faudrait un système de prévision de
pollen plus fiables dix chercheurs y
existe des guides heureusement et puis
il existe des municipalités qui font des
efforts qui se base sur ces guides là
pour prendre des décisions
malheureusement selon qu'ils prennent un
guide ou un autre il arrive à une
conclusion qui est totalement opposé
qu'une espèce vote allergènes ou qu'elle
ne sera pas du tout à preuve cette étude
récente elle évalue le risque d'allergie
à montréal à partir de neuf guides
botanique différents résultats selon le
guide épuisé le risque d'allergie à
montréal est soit très élevé soit
modérée ou soit très faible pour alain
paquet c'est signe qu'il faudrait faire
nos devoirs que vous ne l'êtes c'est
qu'on sait à peu près rien finalement
alors qu'on pensait d'abord ouais sauf
exceptions comme disaient les boulots
par exemple où on a de bonnes idées
qu'effectivement ils sont riches ont des
problèmes ils posent des problèmes
d'allergie alors essentiellement les
armes les espèces qu'on plante en ville
on les connaît pas du point de vue de
leur potentiel
l'an dernier son équipe installée 25
nouvelle station de captage de pollen
sur l'île de montréal qui n'en comptait
qu'une seule on va faire l'analyse
génétique des pollens afin de pouvoir
distinguer par exemple de quel type
d'érable ils proviennent c'est une
nouveauté c'est ça a été très rarement
fait dans le monde 2
donc le but c'est vraiment d'anna lindh
d'identifier les niveaux de l'espèce on
recrute également des dizaines de
volontaires pour faire un lien direct
entre leur période d'allergies et le
type de pollen qui les affectent quand
on prévoit que la hausse de pollen va
être significative et engendrer des
symptômes sévères on pourrait à ce
moment-là pouvoir avertir les les
individus plus à risque plus
susceptibles pour qu'ils puissent mieux
se préparer l'année prochaine la
recherche va s'étendre aux villes de
québec sherbrooke et chicoutimi mais
alain paquet propose déjà des solutions
est la première chose à faire c'est de
diminuer les proportions relative de
chacune des espèces et éviter d'avoir
des espèces qui sont abondants parce
qu'on sait que même si on est allergique
à une espèce il ya en faut quand même
une certaine quantité de pollen avant
qu'on développe une réaction allergique
donc si on diminuait l'abondance des
espèces en les répartissant mieux on
gagne sur tous les plans les résultats
de la recherche devrait être disponible
dans deux ans ici norma grondin radio
canada montréal